By December 8th, blood test results indicate my iron is and ferritid is norra, so your
iron and ferritid are normal, but your hemoglobin is low.
So most likely your iron is at the lower end of normal for your hemoglobin to be low,
your ferritid can be normal or even elevated and have low hemoglobin because ferritid
is a function of iron carrying capacity, but it is also a function of inflammation in your
body.
Also, this person states their lymphocytes are low, how could I increase hemoglobin and
lymphocytes?
Well, you have to determine what if you have low hemoglobin, you have some sort of anemia.
So it could be still iron deficiency anemia, it could be B12 or prodigious anemia, it could
be fallic acid anemia, so there's different types of anemia that you'd have to determine
what that is.
So providing a functional practitioner locally would be the best thing to do, I can't really
do that over Zoom.
I am going to have a bunch of videos on interpreting blood work that will be helpful, but I don't have